opération nettoyage au rez de chaussée
de l'ancien hôpital
ce mini bulldozer déblaie ce qu'il reste
des cloisons al étages supérieurs même
démarche mais cette fois à la main et au
pied de biche
huit ouvriers déconstruisent le site
pièce par pièce
actuellement vous êtes en plein que leur
âge c'est à dire le retrait de tout ce
qui est matériel déchets industriels
banals comme les placoplâtre comme les
mentors l'aluminium le cuivre qui sont
recyclés et retraités ultérieurement
après ou pendant le chantier
c'est un gros boulot tout à fait cela
nécessite énormément de moyens soient
mécaniques purement manuelle ou
mécanique quand vous avez pu constater
au rez de chaussée avec la moyens comme
tels des mini pelles ou démocrate
à l'extérieur plus de la moitié des
bâtiments déjà disparu une fois vidés et
désamianté ceux qui restent seront eux
aussi détruit prochaine étape le
grignotage de l'ancienne crèche et du
bâtiment des internes ici en bleu le
début d'une transformation totale du
quartier
il va y avoir trois cent soixante dix
nouveaux logements qui vont se faire sur
dix ans c'est à dire 30 à 40 logements
neufs nouveaux ce qui est tout à fait
acceptable pour belfort on va mettre
1000 mètres carrés supplémentaires de
square il va y avoir aussi une salle
d'expo temporaire à côté de la donation
jardot au sud
le site de plus de 4 hectares a là aussi
bien changé ici une résidence pour
personnes âgées et un pôle
gérontologique de 73 places verront le
jour
ouverture prévue d'ici la fin de l'année